Star Wars fans may be tough to please
but the crater of the beloved franchise
is even tougher according to rumor
mongering websites we got this covered
George Lucas wasn't just iffy on Star
Wars a rise of Skywalker writer director
JJ Abrams decision to bring back Emperor
Palpatine for the concluding chapter of
the Skywalker saga he was downright
peeved I got a bad feeling about it of
course that websites fights only it's
ever anonymous sources but we have to
say this squares pretty nicely with
remarks made in the past by actor Ian
McDermott who has now portrayed the
nefarious emperor in all three trilogies
speaking with Digital Spy at the UK
premiere of rights of Skywalker
McDermott indicated that so far as Lucas
was concerned bobble team was done after
being chucked down a shaft on the
exploding Death Star - at the end of
1983 s a Star Wars Return of the Jedi
he admitted I thought he was dead
because when we did Return of the Jedi
and I was thrown down that chute to
collect akele he was dead and they asked
Lucas oh does he come back and Lucas
said no he's dead so I just accepted
that he may have beret Brahms did not
according to director Colin Trevorrow it
was initially chapter director rights of
Skywalker Emperor Palpatine to return
was among Abrams first contributions to
the project after he was brought back on
board to replace the Jurassic world
franchise mastermind who departed in
late 2017 also lending credibility to
the reports as a fact that Lucas has
don't have not been totally psyched
about Abrams work on Star Wars The Force
awakens which he felt didn't take enough
chances Disney CEO Bob Iger spelled this
out in his recent memoir the ride of a
lifetime lessons learned from fifteen
years a CEO of the Walt Disney Company
well I guarantee no Lee said it probably
didn't help that Lucas was still having
some difficulty at the time while having
relinquished control of his life's work
the craters criticism was pretty blunt I
Garos just prior to its global release
Lucasfilm president Kathleen Kennedy
screen the force awakens for George he
didn't hide his disappointment there's
nothing new he said in each of the films
in the original trilogy it was important
to him to present new worlds new stories
new characters and new technologies in
this one he said there weren't enough
visual or technical leaps forward Lucas
wasn't the only one who thought so the
force awakens was criticized early and
often for essentially being a remake of
was a new hope at times though it can
seem like we hash in the original
trilogy is exactly what fans wanted from
the sequels the only one of the movies a
gamble with bold narrative choices is
the one they most often criticize and
that also happens to be Lucas's favorite
for the sequel films Lucas responded
most favorably to the last Jedi which
was co-written and directed by Rian
Johnson it's probably not a coincidence
that the last Jedi contains the most
Troy elements from Lucas's original
treatments for the sequels of any of the
three films and the fewest recycled plot
points from previous movies in the
series while Lucas has never commented
on the flick publicly multiple outlets
reported after the last July release
that the creator had spoken with Johnson
according to one of Lucas's
representatives Lucas was complimentary
and sold Johnson that he thought the
film was beautifully made the vast
majority of critics felt the same way
although the last july has proven to be
extremely divisive among the fandom
those same fans though have also taken
rise of Skywalker to task for being too
preoccupied with course-correcting many
of the last Jedi's narrative choices and
for sacrificing coherence and the
interest of cramming in overwhelming
amounts of fanservice he details it's
almost as if the vast majority of Star
Wars fans don't know what in the heck
they want and Disney and Abrams effort
to appease them would have fallen flat
in any event say what you will about
Lucas's prequel films they may have
featured clunky white saying terrible
acting and even worse CGI but at least
they were built on a consistent vision
that Lucas stuck to the better and
ferred well worse this embarrassing
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos buy
your favorite stuff are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and at
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]